how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to the channel yesterday we
got some amazing news as if the hype
around spider-man and the new Spider
verse that is being developed wasn't
enough with spider-man 3 coming out
Morbius coming out and connecting to
spider-man far from home and the next
spider-man film venom 2 and a possible
sinister 6 set up we now have
confirmation that Sony and Marvel
Studios are releasing another spider-man
related film next year and several
insiders say that this film is going to
be a Spider Woman film so let's break
down this report everything we know
about it and what the insiders are
saying that it's going to be if we knew
be sure to subscribe and notification is
turned on so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to Marvel I'm also
giving away an Xbox one or ps4 stick
around to the end for the giveaway
details so today's official announcement
comes from exhibitor relations CO and
they tweeted out Sony's Web continues to
grow untitled Sony / Marvel pic now set
for October 8th 2021 so it's official
Marvel and Sony have a film that they're
doing together of course like all their
spider-man films so far due to
spider-man's rights and it's going to be
coming out next year and of course it is
spider-man related as their tweet says
Sony's Web continues to grow now there
have been a ton of rumored projects that
Sony is supposedly working on we have
Kraven the hunter Night Watch silver
sable black cat Madame web and of course
the sinister six but if we take a look
at the upcoming movie schedule for Sony
and Marvel's projects that are coming up
we can definitely see that they are
planning on something big Morbius is
coming out on July 31st of this year as
well as venom coming out on October 2nd
of this year as well then next year in
2021 the sequel to spider-man far from
home spider-man 3 is going to be coming
out on July 16th and now we have
confirmation that a new film between
Sony and Marvel is going to come just
three months after that so what are Sony
and Marvel planning well it looks like
they are planning on introducing Spider
Woman shortly after we received the news
about this new Sony Marvel film coming
several insiders spoke up about what
they've recently heard Daniel Richman
who was very well known in our community
and has scooped a lot of things and been
right about a lot of a scoop said that
two months ago he heard that they are
developing a Spider Woman movie so it's
likely that this movie is Spider Woman
shortly after MCU
Kosmic backed up this report as well and
then at the same time grace Randolph
from beyond the trailer said that she's
hearing that the new October 2021 date
from Sony / Marvel is for Spider Woman
Jessica drew while Kraven is also being
developed now the fact that Sony and
Marvel would be developing a Spider
Woman film doesn't really come as that
big of a surprise after all there has
been a lot of female superhero leads in
our superhero world recently we've had
one woman and of course Captain Marvel
and now it would make sense that Sony
would want their own female lead enter
Spider Woman Jessica drew now the rights
for Spider Woman between Sony and Marvel
are kind of complicated just like the
rides - Spider Man Spider Woman is
actually a shared character between
Marvel and Sony Marvel can use Jessica
drew in the MCU however they cannot use
the name Spider Woman and also if they
do use Jessica drew she cannot have any
of spider woman's powers and they cannot
use the Spider Woman suit however Sony
does have the rights to use Spider Woman
in her entirety they can call Jessica
drew Spider Woman they can give her all
of her powers and of course they can use
her suit as well now of course as this
has been reported it's going to be a
Sony and Marvel film so you never really
know what kind of deal they've worked
out for Spider Woman and right now as it
stands it's unclear on whether or not
Spider Woman is going to exist in the
MCU or if she's simply going to be in
Sony spider-verse and Tom Hollands
spider-man from the MCU can't appear in
her film because this seems to be the
deal that Marvel has recently worked out
with Sony we saw spider-man in the
Morbius trailer which of course is not
going to be set in the MCU
however events from the MCU spider-man
far from home will affect the movie and
as it's been reported Marvel and Sony
have worked out a deal - where Tom
Hollands spider-man can reference the
events that happened in spider-man 5
from home as long as Sony owns those
characters so that means spider-man is
not going to be able to reference happy
hogan Tony Stark Maria Hill Nick Fury
etc so for our Spider Woman film it may
be that it's not entirely in the MCU but
Tom Hollands spider-man could make an
appearance which is most likely going to
happen because that seems to be Sony's
plan have their own spider-verse with
Tom Hollands spider-man jumping in and
out so this seems to be what we should
expect from this new movie coming out
next year in October a Spider Woman film
that is shared between Marvel and Sony
what do you think about this would you
like to see Spider Woman introduced to
the Sony spider-verse
or what
you rather see something else let me
know what you think in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe and notifications turned on so
you can enter my giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox one or ps4 I'm picking a
winner at five hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof